if you create a sustainable city
a city that has circular principles a
city that engages with the environment
you are creating a healthier population
the problem here is we haven't made that
link
between circular design and
livelihoods yeah you know the elementary
foundation
talks about this idea of secular economy
pioneers
a lot of the things that i wanted to to
learn
about nobody is teaching right or
they've only been teaching it
for the past five years like it's all so
new
that in a way you couldn't have done it
before so then but
then you leave the footprints for people
to follow exactly
right you you you are creating that new
path
i mean this is the reason why people
like us are interested in circular
design
it's not just for what it means now but
for what it means
in 50 100 years right yeah now we have
to create that narrative which
makes people appreciate that okay
sustainability is very very important
to be able to take care of my children
my family even myself yeah
you